here in this video we shall discuss what
happened in the monsterverse between the
events of godzilla king of the monsters
with the subsequent death of most zero
and the events of godzilla vs kong with
the beginning of godzilla's attacks on
apex bases so we will talk a bit on each
specific event and also estimate our own
timings for these monster sightings
which were only vaguely mentioned in the
master verse so what do you say shall we
get down to business
2019 godzilla becomes the king of the
monsters with a couple of thermonuclear
explosions the nuclear pulse the g-man
marked the end of master zero and he
regains his title asking of the monsters
again with rodan and the other titans
showing up in boston and bowing to him
in the same year humans battle against
camazotz on the other side of the
country in san diego there was another
titan that heeded the call of ghidorah
and only went back into the hollow earth
after a showdown with fighter jets and
the air force
this was the bat titan called camazotz
in the same year again calm kills the
remaining skullcrawlers on skull island
meanwhile in skull island the
skullcrawlers begin to emerge out and
join ghidorah but were hunted down and
killed by kong who himself ignored the
alpha call and did what he wanted
later in the same year alan jonah
acquires the ghidorah skull
after the battle of boston and godzilla
being crowned the king of the world the
world was in disarray but alan jonah
managed to get information on one of the
skulls of ghidorah being found in the
coast of mexico and therefore acquired
it for apex cybernetics
mid to late 2019 the titans rejuvenate
the natural environment with the battle
over godzilla send the titles back to
their own domains and it was discovered
that just as with the murders in las
vegas and san francisco the other titans
as well with their radiation and
excretions are rejuvenating the natural
ecosystems and at the same time
prehistoric lost species of ancient
vegetation are making a comeback
2019 till 2020
talents are sent back into hibernation
godzilla realizes that the awakening of
the titans by ghidorah was chaotic and
too many of his brethren have come out
of hibernation all at once and therefore
he decides to send them back all of them
into slumber until the time is needed
for them to come back online
early 2020 godzilla battled cilla
as silla was attacking a group of ships
trying to obtain a nuclear bomb to feed
her hunger godzilla intervenes annabel
ensues with the big g quickly
dispatching the cephalopod titan and
kicks it to the curb
early 2020 again amherst battles
behemoth and godzilla not so long after
the incident with scilla godzilla comes
to the amazon forest and witnesses a
battle between behemoth and amhuluk with
the latter getting the upper hand until
godzilla comes in between and smacks the
new titan back into the water
unspecified
godzilla battles janitor swarm
godzilla swimming under the sea descends
into the hollow earth to rest in his old
place as godzilla descends a colossal
staircase into his former lair he is
swarmed by a host of unfamiliar
creatures which is the janitor swarm and
was attacked head-on by the leader of
the swamp which is just a sub-titan but
he managed to destroy them all in a
short span of time
early 2021 monarch's mission into the
hollow earth the brother of nathan lynn
david lynn goes on a mission into the
hollow earth under the flagship of
monarch from skull island but the
mission ended disastrously as the
mission did not take into account the
gravity inversion and the wormhole
effect of the entrance into the hollow
earth
early 2021 gong battles camazotz
as a perpetual storm with winds over 400
miles per hour heads for skull island a
new titan emerges the king of the deep
as prophesized by the eewee this titan
is none other than camazotz which comes
out and challenges kong trying to kill
him but with the help of humans kong
manages to defeat gamzotz and send him
back into the hollow earth with a
gigantic punch
again in early 2021 the storm destroys
skull island after the events of kingdom
kong and the instability of skull island
caused by monarch trying to enter the
hollow earth the perpetual storm that
was created during kotm envelops the
island and makes it uninhabitable kong
saves jia in the process and forms a
strong bond with the ewe child
mid-2021 the kong containment facility
is built at some point after the storm
enveloped skull island monarch puts
extensive resources and work to build a
facility number 236 which is a massive
dome containment zone for kong and the
surviving creatures of skull island
again in mid-2021 godzilla frees titanos
nakika godzilla continues his search for
a new home led on by mothra's gif of
life but then senses something calling
out from the deeps in pain he discovers
a titan called nakika which was trapped
in a massive net and then he proceeds to
free her and then proceeds again to
destroy a submarine and an oil platform
operated by people trying to capture the
mysterious titan
august 2021 eileen andrews becomes the
kong whisperer monarch scientist dr
eileen andrews becomes quite famous
after the establishment of kong's
containment zone on skull island she is
labeled the kong whisperer and put on
the cover of scientific future
late 2021 godzilla battles tiamat
godzilla finds himself under attack by
tiamat during his search for his new
home the serpentine titan calls her body
around godzilla and pulls him down in
the underwater with a maelstrom
initially getting the upper hand tiemout
kept on battling godzilla until the
fight was taken on lan and the big g
then decimates the rival with powerful
blows and sends her fleeing back into
the ocean with a massive massive roar
late 2021 the last sighting of titans
with kong defeating camazotz and
godzilla's winds against silla amherst
janitor and tiamat all the other tyrants
were sent into hibernation and with that
comes a lull in titan sightings around
the world and the only ones above ground
are godzilla and kong
unspecified antarctica facility was
built
in a timeframe between king of the
monsters and godzilla vs com and also
with the destruction of the hollow earth
entry in skull island the only
accessible point discovered in
antarctica was developed into a giant
facility by monarch 2021 until 2024 apec
cybernetics begins work on mecca
godzilla apex cybernetics which was a
corporation founded in 2014 after the
emergence of the murders and the bell in
san francisco begins work on a
mechanical titan built on the image of
godzilla and designed to counter future
titan threats
2021 until 2024 apex captures skull
crawls for tests it is unknown as to how
apex manages its operations but the
eventual commissioning of mecha godzilla
required tests against hostile titans
skull crawlers were acquired as well as
their eggs to be killed in the
sacrificial pit of the mecca g
and 2024 the events of godzilla vs kong
and so now we come to the domed
enclosure in skull island where kong
wakes up and starts throwing trees as
javelins into the enclosure walls
whereas elsewhere gaza attacks apex
bases around the world triggered by
guitar's biosignal from the mecca parts
that are being constructed and assembled
and so with that we come to the end of
the video so do hit that like button for
support and click on that subscribe
button as well to be a part of the mind
cue family but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
master content right here on this
channel
till the next one take care fam